all throughout my life I've had a strong
interest in justice issues I grew up in
the south outside of Atlanta and there
at very young ages I was exposed to some
severe racism and became dedicated to
trying to address it I ended up working
for the Martin Luther King Center for
nonviolent social change I became very
involved in my community and the issue
of justice and the fact that so many
people don't have access to it was
something that I was security aware as
well as aware of my own privilege and
opportunities perhaps to do some things
about it that inspired me to go to law
school and when I went to law school I
had the honor of representing a young
woman who was from West Africa and she
was fleeing a forced marriage where she
would have been the fourth wife of a 45
year old man at the age of 17 and she
was fleeing female genital mutilation a
very life-threatening cultural practice
that several of her cousins had died
from and she entered the u.s.
immigration system because she was
honest having fled here she passed off
her passport to the immigration
authorities and said this is not mine
but I have fled for my life under these
circumstances and as a result as a 17
year old whose only crime was to flee
violence and to want justice she was
placed in our immigration detention
center and then also spent many months
in maximum-security prison with American
convicted felons and during that time as
a law student I represented her I argued
her case before the immigration judge we
lost and then I took her case to
American University where I was a law
student and worked there on her case on
appeal and it was appealed to the
highest immigration appellate court and
at that level she won and her case set
national precedent and established for
the first time that what we now call
gender-based persecution because of
female genital mutilation in her case
can be a grounds for refugee status or
asylum in the United States prior to
that things that happen to women simply
because they were women was not
considered a basis for protection so her
case had a tremendous influence on the
law and the United States recognition of
these things as a result of the
publicity in her case I began getting
phone calls from women and girls who
were desperate for help as a law student
I was ill-equipped to assist them and
then there was also commercial interest
in her story and my story is helping her
as a law student and so she and I wrote
a book together called do they hear you
when you cry and I used all of my
portion of the proceeds of that book to
start the Taher a Justice Center the
Tyree Justice Center provides free legal
and other services to immigrant women
and girls who are utilizing u.s. law to
reject a violence and seek justice and
so they face a wide range of things like
female genital mutilation honor crimes
forced marriage rape domestic violence
and they come from all over the world no
culture no community no religion is
immune from violence against women and
they represent that and so tari meets
that need the women who come to us are
desperate in the moment they come but
they're incredibly courageous and heroic
women and they can demand justice for
themselves they will rebuild their lives
and they will change their communities
their cultures and their family but in
that moment when they've rejected
violence and in that moment when they've
come to us they need a lawyer and they
need a helping hand and so that's what
we do we support them with legal
services that are free we help them
access justice and we help them rebuild
their lives because of course justice
has only found partially in the
courtroom there's a lot of other stuff
that goes into it and so we also support
them with psychology therapy medical
services emergency housing job skills
training and that kind of thing when the
tire age
dissenters clients come to us they lack
the resources that many us-born women
have they are statutorily ineligible for
legal aid in the same way that US
citizens have access to it their lack of
English may make are already foreign
culture and laws even less accessible to
them they often lack a network of family
and friends and financial resources and
so they are extremely vulnerable and we
help meet that need by providing free
legal services